Speaker 1: So I want to speak a little bit about my
Speaker 1: understanding of the nature of the soul as
Speaker 1: it relates to the awakened, to enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, and keep in mind that when we
Speaker 1: are speaking about such deep matters and
Speaker 1: the soul is a very deep matter we're
Speaker 1: entering into speculative inquiry.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to share with you what I my my
Speaker 1: personal understanding, what I've come to,
Speaker 1: but it's all.
Speaker 1: It's all.
Speaker 1: It's all a work in progress, remains a work
Speaker 1: in progress.
Speaker 1: I'm a work in progress, my ideas are a work
Speaker 1: in progress, but I think, I think some of
Speaker 1: the distinctions I'm going to try and make,
Speaker 1: some of you might find helpful.
Speaker 1: So, just to be clear that, because I'm a
Speaker 1: teacher of enlightenment, everything that I
Speaker 1: speak about relates to the metaphysical
Speaker 1: context of the highest spiritual
Speaker 1: transformation, the most profound shift in
Speaker 1: consciousness that we know about, when it
Speaker 1: leads to unimaginable liberation and inner
Speaker 1: freedom and joy and happiness, contentment.
Speaker 1: So I'll speak.
Speaker 1: I want to describe a simple map, a way to
Speaker 1: help you understand these distinctions in
Speaker 1: the context in which I'm speaking about it.
Speaker 1: So the soul, in the way we use the word,
Speaker 1: usually refers to one of the deepest parts
Speaker 1: of our humanity.
Speaker 1: One of the deepest parts of our humanity
Speaker 1: when we usually refer to our soul or the
Speaker 1: soul, we're referring to a level of
Speaker 1: emotional and spiritual depth that is
Speaker 1: inherently meaningful.
Speaker 1: When people start speaking about the soul,
Speaker 1: we know that they're not speaking about
Speaker 1: superficial matters.
Speaker 1: They're speaking about matters that are
Speaker 1: deep and sincere and serious.
Speaker 1: So I want to talk about the nature of the
Speaker 1: soul in relationship to enlightenment.
Speaker 1: So so at the.
Speaker 1: So we want to start with looking at the
Speaker 1: nature of the ego.
Speaker 1: The ego is the frontal cell.
Speaker 1: The ego is the.
Speaker 1: It plays a dominant role in the formation
Speaker 1: of the self-structure.
Speaker 1: It, the ego, is the organizing principle in
Speaker 1: the psyche.
Speaker 1: It creates coherence.
Speaker 1: So it's just to speak in very broad,
Speaker 1: general terms.
Speaker 1: If the ego is that structure in the psyche
Speaker 1: that creates coherence or a sense of
Speaker 1: wholeness, then we want that.
Speaker 1: That when the ego structure is not coherent
Speaker 1: or is incoherent, then usually the person
Speaker 1: is in trouble of some kind.
Speaker 1: So the ego is the ego very much relates to
Speaker 1: the.
Speaker 1: In the way that I'm speaking about it now
Speaker 1: very much relates to the structure of the
Speaker 1: personality, and in the way I'm speaking
Speaker 1: about it now, we can interchangeably use
Speaker 1: the word ego to mean, in this context, the
Speaker 1: nature of Andrew's personality, the nature
Speaker 1: of Andrew's ego, for example, in the way
Speaker 1: I'm speaking about it now.
Speaker 1: I'm not speaking about the ego as a demon,
Speaker 1: because often in enlightenment contexts,
Speaker 1: the ego as a demon, because often in
Speaker 1: enlightenment contexts, the ego is the
Speaker 1: demon that we need to transcend in order to
Speaker 1: be spiritually liberated, which is also
Speaker 1: true.
Speaker 1: But that's not the context in which I'm
Speaker 1: speaking about it for this talk.
Speaker 1: So for this talk, we want to understand the
Speaker 1: ego structure.
Speaker 1: Is the, is that structure that coheres the
Speaker 1: personality?
Speaker 1: It creates a healthy, integrated frontal
Speaker 1: self, what Ken Wilber would call the
Speaker 1: frontal self.
Speaker 1: And just to add to that, of course, the ego
Speaker 1: can have positive expressions and negative
Speaker 1: expressions.
Speaker 1: It can be a positive ego and a negative ego,
Speaker 1: a happy ego and a sad ego, a joyous ego and
Speaker 1: an angry ego, a liberated ego and a
Speaker 1: victimized ego.
Speaker 1: I'm sure you all know what I'm talking
Speaker 1: about from your own experience.
Speaker 1: But the ego, the ego is not the deepest
Speaker 1: part of the self, and so whenever we hear
Speaker 1: people refer to the soul, refer to my, I
Speaker 1: feel it in my soul.
Speaker 1: I could feel it in my soul, I could feel it
Speaker 1: in her soul we were always pointing.
Speaker 1: When we speak that way, we were generally
Speaker 1: pointing to a deeper structure in the self,
Speaker 1: a deeper structure than the frontal self, a
Speaker 1: deeper structure than the personality, than
Speaker 1: the ego personality, referring to a deeper
Speaker 1: dimension of the self that generally is
Speaker 1: considered to be more authentic and carry
Speaker 1: more truth, whatever that means.
Speaker 1: I'm just saying that usually, when we
Speaker 1: ourselves refer to our own souls or the
Speaker 1: soul of another, we're referring to deeper
Speaker 1: dimensions of the self than is the, than
Speaker 1: that of the ego or the frontal personality.
Speaker 1: He has a very deep soul, she is a deep soul,
Speaker 1: she's an old soul, for example.
Speaker 1: So I was talking about the nature of the
Speaker 1: ego, the soul and the true self and the
Speaker 1: true self is the deepest is, from a
Speaker 1: spiritual perspective, from a metaphysical
Speaker 1: perspective, from the perspective of the
Speaker 1: perennial philosophy, the true self is the
Speaker 1: deepest dimension of the self and the
Speaker 1: deepest dimension of reality itself.
Speaker 1: So the ego is relates to our personal
Speaker 1: history, the soul relates to, I believe,
Speaker 1: all the experience we've ever had as an
Speaker 1: evolving soul or, if one would believe it
Speaker 1: or think that way, over many lifetimes.
Speaker 1: And the self, the true self, exists in a
Speaker 1: realm of dimension and reality that is
Speaker 1: timeless and formless and beginning and
Speaker 1: endless and ultimately eternal.
Speaker 1: And remember, when I'm speaking about the
Speaker 1: ego and the soul and the true self, I'm
Speaker 1: speaking about myself, I'm speaking about
Speaker 1: yourself.
Speaker 1: So when we make these kinds of distinctions,
Speaker 1: we don't want to get too abstract about it,
Speaker 1: but we want to relate to, we want to try
Speaker 1: and locate the sense of being an ego or a
Speaker 1: unique personality within ourself.
Speaker 1: As we're on an inquiry like this, we want
Speaker 1: to find our own ego and we want to find our
Speaker 1: own soul, which is a good thing to find.
Speaker 1: People that haven't found their own souls
Speaker 1: are generally not in great shape and, for
Speaker 1: the seekers after enlightenment, we want to
Speaker 1: find our true self.
Speaker 1: Our true self is the part of ourself
Speaker 1: because it is one with eternity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where we find unconditional
Speaker 1: freedom, because it's a place where time
Speaker 1: does not exist.
Speaker 1: The true self is a source of spiritual
Speaker 1: freedom yeah, inner freedom, spiritual
Speaker 1: liberation.
Speaker 1: So the ego is the source of the feelings of
Speaker 1: being a unique personal entity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where we experience pride, the
Speaker 1: experience of the process that most of us
Speaker 1: find ourselves in the midst of, of having a
Speaker 1: personal experience.
Speaker 1: It's when experience, it happens in time,
Speaker 1: it's when experience feels very personal
Speaker 1: and unique.
Speaker 1: To me, the ego is the source of this
Speaker 1: feeling of a personal process, of a
Speaker 1: personal event happening.
Speaker 1: That's the self-structure in which feels,
Speaker 1: in which the experience of embodied
Speaker 1: consciousness is experienced as being a
Speaker 1: personal event, something that's happening
Speaker 1: to a unique self of me.
Speaker 1: So I always like to say that the soul, what
Speaker 1: I'm calling the soul, is the deepest part
Speaker 1: of the self that's still personal.
Speaker 1: So the soul is the deepest part of the self
Speaker 1: that's still personal.
Speaker 1: So the soul comes from a much deeper source
Speaker 1: and I like to refer to the soul as the
Speaker 1: metaphysical organ.
Speaker 1: We could call it that, for lack of a better
Speaker 1: way of putting it.
Speaker 1: The soul is a metaphysical organ that
Speaker 1: carries with it.
Speaker 1: If you believe in the continuity of
Speaker 1: consciousness and I very much believe I
Speaker 1: can't prove it to you, but I very much
Speaker 1: believe in the continuity of consciousness
Speaker 1: I believe that the self, or that our soul,
Speaker 1: is on a journey of becoming, in a context
Speaker 1: of evolution, just like just with the rest
Speaker 1: of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: So the soul would be the receptacle which
Speaker 1: would contain all the memories of all the
Speaker 1: experiences you've ever had, going back to
Speaker 1: the very beginning of time and even the
Speaker 1: beginning of the universe.
Speaker 1: I believe that when I say it's something I
Speaker 1: believe.
Speaker 1: It's something that I'm.
Speaker 1: It's really a belief, I can't prove to you,
Speaker 1: but the soul is the metaphysical vessel
Speaker 1: that remains a constant and that is, I
Speaker 1: believe that, a process of growth and
Speaker 1: development through different incarnations
Speaker 1: and different processes of embodied
Speaker 1: consciousness over time.
Speaker 1: But the soul is a place where we experience
Speaker 1: our deepest emotions, our deepest feelings
Speaker 1: that still have a connection to our
Speaker 1: personal sense of self identity.
Speaker 1: But these are deeper kinds of feelings.
Speaker 1: We could say in this context that the ego
Speaker 1: experiences all kinds of emotions and
Speaker 1: feelings, likes and dislikes.
Speaker 1: But the preferences and likes and dislikes
Speaker 1: of the ego in this context would be
Speaker 1: considered to be much more superficial in
Speaker 1: general than the feelings that we
Speaker 1: experience at the level of our souls.
Speaker 1: So, for example, maybe we meet, as some
Speaker 1: people like to talk about, maybe we meet
Speaker 1: our soulmate.
Speaker 1: When I met her I recognized instantaneously
Speaker 1: and miraculously that she was my soulmate
Speaker 1: and that we'd been waiting for each other
Speaker 1: for years.
Speaker 1: That kind of thing.
Speaker 1: It's when we experience deeper kinds of
Speaker 1: non-superficial, deeper kinds of feelings
Speaker 1: that relate to our experience of life, but
Speaker 1: these feelings are occurring in a much
Speaker 1: deeper strata, a dimension of experience.
Speaker 1: We feel deeper connections and deeper
Speaker 1: contexts, maybe a deeper sense of meaning
Speaker 1: and also maybe a deeper sense of loss and
Speaker 1: grief, relationships and loss and grief.
Speaker 1: But the soul is the dimension of ourself
Speaker 1: where we experience our deepest feelings
Speaker 1: that are still related to ourselves
Speaker 1: personally but are much deeper than the
Speaker 1: realm of the kinds of emotions we
Speaker 1: experience at the level of the ego, which
Speaker 1: is much more superficial.
Speaker 1: And of course, the idea in terms of
Speaker 1: spiritual evolution is to train ourselves
Speaker 1: to cease to experience life from the
Speaker 1: vantage point that is so superficial to a
Speaker 1: vantage point perspective that's much
Speaker 1: deeper, much more authentic, much more
Speaker 1: meaningful and therefore has inherently
Speaker 1: greater value.
Speaker 1: One feels with people that are very
Speaker 1: superficial that they're just skirting
Speaker 1: along on the surface of life because
Speaker 1: they're not connected to any deeper parts
Speaker 1: of themselves or deeper parts of reality,
Speaker 1: and that can be tedious and unsatisfying
Speaker 1: for people with greater depth.
Speaker 1: But when you meet people who have greater
Speaker 1: depth, you feel that you're meeting them at
Speaker 1: the level of the soul and then there seems
Speaker 1: to be a sense of greater value in those
Speaker 1: kinds of connections and experiences.
Speaker 1: Value, purpose meaning, gravitas, value and
Speaker 1: those kinds of connections and experiences,
Speaker 1: value, purpose meaning, gravitas, sense of
Speaker 1: this means something of value.
Speaker 1: This is very important.
Speaker 1: This kind of feeling gives the experience
Speaker 1: of being alive value and meaning, which is
Speaker 1: so important in the human experience.
Speaker 1: Experience value now this when we go deeper
Speaker 1: than that, the realm of the self, of the
Speaker 1: true self that spiritual realizers refer to
Speaker 1: as the true self, that's the realm of
Speaker 1: eternity consciousness, of non-dual
Speaker 1: eternity consciousness.
Speaker 1: So the deepest dimension of the self, which
Speaker 1: is synonymous with the deepest dimension of
Speaker 1: reality itself, is a place where we
Speaker 1: experience the deepest quality and
Speaker 1: experience of I-ness, of selfness, of
Speaker 1: I-ness.
Speaker 1: But at that level of depth it's completely
Speaker 1: impersonal.
Speaker 1: There's no unique characteristics or
Speaker 1: features to the true self.
Speaker 1: The true self is often referred to as the
Speaker 1: ground of being.
Speaker 1: So it's an eternal ground that exists
Speaker 1: beyond time and beyond space, and beyond
Speaker 1: form and beyond conception.
Speaker 1: But it's a place where you and I experience
Speaker 1: the fullest, deepest and most profound
Speaker 1: experience of conscious existence.
Speaker 1: But at that level we experience ourself as
Speaker 1: existing eternally for eternity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where our awareness is
Speaker 1: absolute, existing eternally for eternity.
Speaker 1: It's a place where awareness is absolute
Speaker 1: and existence is, as I was saying, eternal,
Speaker 1: and it is absolutely and totally unrelated
Speaker 1: to any kind of relative experience that
Speaker 1: your soul or that your ego has in any other
Speaker 1: kind of context or that your ego has in any
Speaker 1: other kind of context.
Speaker 1: So we have the ego, positive and negative.
Speaker 1: We have the soul, we have the true self Now,
Speaker 1: the soul, which is, as I've been saying,
Speaker 1: which is the deepest part of the yourself
Speaker 1: and myself.
Speaker 1: That's still personal.
Speaker 1: It's where we experience our deepest, our
Speaker 1: deeper and more significant feelings and
Speaker 1: preferences and fears and yearnings and
Speaker 1: values.
Speaker 1: What we experience in our soul depends upon
Speaker 1: our level of consciousness development on
Speaker 1: one hand, and on the other hand, it depends
Speaker 1: on what we hold as being most dear or the
Speaker 1: greatest value to us hold as being most
Speaker 1: dear and the greatest value to us.
Speaker 1: So in integral philosophy they had some
Speaker 1: basic, basic distinctions in terms of the
Speaker 1: evolutionary stages that the self goes
Speaker 1: through, and we'll just go through the most
Speaker 1: basic ones for the sake of the talk on the
Speaker 1: everything here.
Speaker 1: It's tonight, where you are might be
Speaker 1: morning, but the lowest level is called
Speaker 1: egocentric and at the egocentric level is
Speaker 1: the consciousness of the small child, of
Speaker 1: the baby, who is completely identified with
Speaker 1: his or her biological impulses, his or her
Speaker 1: biological impulses, his or her fears and
Speaker 1: desires.
Speaker 1: It's a state of uncontained, absolute
Speaker 1: narcissism and self-concern.
Speaker 1: It's a place we all start from and a place
Speaker 1: some of us, hopefully, will graduate from
Speaker 1: at some point in our evolutionary ascent,
Speaker 1: but some people never do so.
Speaker 1: Egocentric, the next stage of the
Speaker 1: self-development is called ethnocentric
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: It's called ethnocentric and at the
Speaker 1: ethnocentric level we identify very much
Speaker 1: with our bloodline, with our family and our
Speaker 1: tribe.
Speaker 1: It's tribal consciousness.
Speaker 1: That's where our self sense is very
Speaker 1: intensely identified with our clan, with
Speaker 1: our tribe, with our family, that kind of
Speaker 1: blood belonging.
Speaker 1: And next level is world-centric, which is a
Speaker 1: very high level of consciousness
Speaker 1: development, which is considered to be the
Speaker 1: leading edge in the world today, which is
Speaker 1: the identity, which is the identification,
Speaker 1: the universal nature of being a human being.
Speaker 1: I see myself first and foremost as a human
Speaker 1: being, as a member of the human family.
Speaker 1: So an individual at a world-centric,
Speaker 1: universal human level of development will
Speaker 1: see all human beings as his brothers and
Speaker 1: his sisters.
Speaker 1: And the highest level, the one level beyond
Speaker 1: that which is the goal that all spiritual
Speaker 1: seekers after enlightenment yearn for and
Speaker 1: work towards, is called cosmocentric.
Speaker 1: The cosmocentric level is when we identify
Speaker 1: with the evolutionary process itself as a
Speaker 1: source of our self-sense.
Speaker 1: I am the energy and intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe, bearing witness to
Speaker 1: itself and awakening to itself through the
Speaker 1: body, mind, personality of Andrew or any
Speaker 1: one of you.
Speaker 1: So we have these basic, simple distinctions
Speaker 1: here.
Speaker 1: There are more distinctions, but I'm trying
Speaker 1: to keep it very simple because of the point
Speaker 1: I want to make in this talk.
Speaker 1: So we have egocentric, ethnocentric
Speaker 1: identifying with the clan and the bloodline,
Speaker 1: world-centric, universal, human and
Speaker 1: cosmocentric identification with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary principle itself and
Speaker 1: Cosmocentric Identification with the
Speaker 1: Evolutionary Principle itself.
Speaker 1: Now, the fundamental point I want to make
Speaker 1: is that what I'm calling the soul here,
Speaker 1: what I'm keep on referring to as the soul,
Speaker 1: this very, this deepest part of the self
Speaker 1: that's still personal, where we have these
Speaker 1: very powerful and profound emotions that
Speaker 1: carry with them a great sense of importance
Speaker 1: and gravitas and significance.
Speaker 1: What you will feel in your soul as being
Speaker 1: that of the greatest importance depends
Speaker 1: upon which state of consciousness you are
Speaker 1: resting in.
Speaker 1: So if you are, if you're at an ethnocentric
Speaker 1: stage of development where your primary
Speaker 1: identification is with your family or your
Speaker 1: tribe or your blood group, your clan, the
Speaker 1: deepest feelings that you'll experience in
Speaker 1: your soul, your soul felt emotions, the
Speaker 1: strongest emotions positive and negative
Speaker 1: place where you experience the most
Speaker 1: gravitas emotionally, will stem from your
Speaker 1: will, stem from that level of development.
Speaker 1: So your strongest feelings and your soul
Speaker 1: will relate to your identification with
Speaker 1: being part of a particular tribe or a
Speaker 1: particular family and your strongest
Speaker 1: emotions are going to be very related to
Speaker 1: that stage of development.
Speaker 1: And we know, when people start to feel
Speaker 1: strong feelings in their soul, they're
Speaker 1: capable of great heroism in one hand and
Speaker 1: great evil on the other.
Speaker 1: Because when we feel strong emotions in our
Speaker 1: soul, because it's coming from our soul, we
Speaker 1: tend to never doubt the inherent value and
Speaker 1: what we imagine as the inherent
Speaker 1: truthfulness of what we're experiencing,
Speaker 1: because the feelings are so strong at that
Speaker 1: level, we feel these feelings so strongly
Speaker 1: at that level that we feel this is truth.
Speaker 1: That's why when we meet somebody that we
Speaker 1: consider to be our soulmate, it's so
Speaker 1: powerful, I have no doubt I've been waiting
Speaker 1: for you for a hundred lifetimes.
Speaker 1: Maybe it's true, maybe it's not true, but
Speaker 1: because we feel it so intensely in our soul,
Speaker 1: we have no doubt that it's true.
Speaker 1: So egocentric, ethnocentric, so it's the
Speaker 1: same thing with world-centric, universal
Speaker 1: human values and feelings.
Speaker 1: A lot of people, for very noble reasons,
Speaker 1: feel at the level of their soul how
Speaker 1: important it is that there's human rights
Speaker 1: and fairness and justice in this world and
Speaker 1: world and the flourishing of liberal
Speaker 1: democracies and the freedom for women and
Speaker 1: oppressed peoples.
Speaker 1: Everywhere.
Speaker 1: It comes to the end of racism and sexism
Speaker 1: and patriarchy and so many things, because
Speaker 1: we recognize that all human beings are part
Speaker 1: of one species.
Speaker 1: We're all brothers and sisters and
Speaker 1: therefore we need to make this world a fair
Speaker 1: place.
Speaker 1: But some people feel that in their soul
Speaker 1: this is a soul felt conviction, not
Speaker 1: something that is just believed and
Speaker 1: understood with the mind.
Speaker 1: It's a soul level.
Speaker 1: It's a soul felt conviction and when you
Speaker 1: feel something like that so strongly in
Speaker 1: your soul, it's something you might be
Speaker 1: willing to die for and fight for.
Speaker 1: It's not a judgment, I'm just trying.
Speaker 1: And then we go from world-centric to
Speaker 1: Cosmic-centric.
Speaker 1: So when you which is a very rare level of
Speaker 1: attainment I am the energy and intelligence
Speaker 1: that created the universe, bearing witness
Speaker 1: to itself through the body, mind and
Speaker 1: personality of each and every one of us,
Speaker 1: that's when we relate to and identify with
Speaker 1: the evolutionary process from our souls.
Speaker 1: That's when it becomes a.
Speaker 1: There's a realness about that stage of
Speaker 1: development that becomes different because
Speaker 1: we feel it in our souls.
Speaker 1: So one of the points I wanted to make was
Speaker 1: that many of us relate to our experience,
Speaker 1: to our intellects.
Speaker 1: We're capable of so much understanding.
Speaker 1: We understand egocentrism or narcissism.
Speaker 1: We understand ethnocentric, tribal
Speaker 1: perspectives and feelings.
Speaker 1: At least to a point we recognize feelings
Speaker 1: of universality, the universal nature of
Speaker 1: being human, which is a world-centric
Speaker 1: perspective, and world-centric feelings,
Speaker 1: and then there's cosmocentric.
Speaker 1: So what I'm saying is we can understand
Speaker 1: these distinctions with our intellects, we
Speaker 1: can appreciate them intellectually,
Speaker 1: metaphorically, at a level of abstraction.
Speaker 1: And then there's the level of actual
Speaker 1: feeling, of deep soul level feeling.
Speaker 1: And one of the points I wanted to make was
Speaker 1: that the when we experience these
Speaker 1: distinctions at a soul level, we no longer
Speaker 1: experience, we know that we're not just
Speaker 1: understanding these distinctions at a soul
Speaker 1: level, we're not just understanding these
Speaker 1: distinctions at a level of mind and mental
Speaker 1: or intellectual abstraction, but we're
Speaker 1: understanding them with our gut, with our
Speaker 1: soul, the deepest nature of ourself.
Speaker 1: And because, basically, what I'm speaking
Speaker 1: about has to do with what is it that we
Speaker 1: care about the most, what is it that you
Speaker 1: care about the most, what is it that I care
Speaker 1: about the most?
Speaker 1: Because what we care about the most will be
Speaker 1: reflected in our soul level, in this
Speaker 1: experience we're having at the level of our
Speaker 1: souls.
Speaker 1: So what do you really care about the most?
Speaker 1: What you care about the most is what you
Speaker 1: feel in your soul, and a big part of the
Speaker 1: higher and more profound levels of
Speaker 1: spiritual transformation has to do with, I
Speaker 1: believe, the evolution of our capacity to
Speaker 1: care about higher matters at the level of
Speaker 1: our souls.
Speaker 1: To repeat, I believe that a very
Speaker 1: significant part of what higher spiritual
Speaker 1: development is about is learning how to
Speaker 1: care, learning what it means to deeply care,
Speaker 1: in this case about the evolution of
Speaker 1: consciousness, not from your mind, not
Speaker 1: appreciating that this would be a very good
Speaker 1: idea and makes reasonable sense, but that
Speaker 1: you begin to care because your soul has
Speaker 1: awakened to that level of consciousness, to
Speaker 1: its significance, and then you begin to
Speaker 1: care, beyond what your mind may think from
Speaker 1: time to time, about the evolution of
Speaker 1: consciousness for its own sake, because
Speaker 1: your soul has awakened to that level of
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: So the soul has to do with what do you care
Speaker 1: about the most?
Speaker 1: Where are you rooted in your, your deepest,
Speaker 1: your deepest preferences?
Speaker 1: Now, when we look at that question
Speaker 1: superficially, we find that for most people
Speaker 1: it's egoic self-concern, survival at lower
Speaker 1: levels and beyond survival.
Speaker 1: It has to do with egocentric, unfortunately
Speaker 1: often materialistic survival, materialistic
Speaker 1: self-concern and narcissistic self-concern,
Speaker 1: not an awakened souls feeling of
Speaker 1: overwhelming value about the nature and the
Speaker 1: nature and inherent meaning of
Speaker 1: self-existence, the significance of
Speaker 1: consciousness and the significance of the
Speaker 1: evolution of the cosmos.
Speaker 1: What are you living for?
Speaker 1: Because we can't really live for spirit and
Speaker 1: for these higher spiritual values unless we
Speaker 1: have awakened, at the level of the soul,
Speaker 1: these higher principles.
Speaker 1: So the question I'm asking is where is any
Speaker 1: one of us at the level people?
Speaker 1: Our soul is very much related to
Speaker 1: materialistic concerns and narcissistic
Speaker 1: concerns, ethnocentric concerns.
Speaker 1: But when your soul is related to these
Speaker 1: deeper dimensions of the self and deeper
Speaker 1: dimensions of reality, this is when
Speaker 1: spiritual evolution begins to happen for
Speaker 1: real.
Speaker 1: It's when you become a truly transformed
Speaker 1: sentient being.
Speaker 1: That's when the soul begins to, when the
Speaker 1: soul literally begins to identify itself
Speaker 1: with unqualified spirit and something
Speaker 1: really changes in each and every one of us
Speaker 1: at the deepest level.
Speaker 1: It's when your soul gets so drenched in the
Speaker 1: consciousness of eternity, for example,
Speaker 1: that it's something you can't forget, you
Speaker 1: can't turn away from.
Speaker 1: You've been so deeply touched that your
Speaker 1: soul is now awakened to eternity and it's
Speaker 1: something that your soul knows about.
Speaker 1: Now your soul knows about eternity.
Speaker 1: It's not that your ego had a great
Speaker 1: experience that it remembers, but it's
Speaker 1: something that your soul had a great
Speaker 1: something that you know, it's something
Speaker 1: that your soul knows and your soul the soul,
Speaker 1: never forgets.
Speaker 1: The soul is the most important part of each
Speaker 1: and every one of us.
Speaker 1: The soul is the source of our integrity, or
Speaker 1: lack of integrity.
Speaker 1: The soul is where we find our capacity for
Speaker 1: wholeness and integration.
Speaker 1: Deep kindness, unselfish deep kindness,
Speaker 1: love, loyalty, care, selflessness or not, I
Speaker 1: believe it's the soul, it's that dimension
Speaker 1: of ourselves where we have that rude
Speaker 1: awakening.
Speaker 1: Rude awakening is when you get a glimpse of
Speaker 1: the totality of reality, whatever way it
Speaker 1: happens, and you glimpse, for maybe an
Speaker 1: instant, where you're really at in
Speaker 1: relationship to the experience of being
Speaker 1: human.
Speaker 1: For a moment, you glimpse your true motives,
Speaker 1: and it may be a rude awakening.
Speaker 1: You might find out that you're not as true,
Speaker 1: authentic and pure, well-meaning as you may
Speaker 1: imagine yourself to be, or you may find
Speaker 1: that you are.
Speaker 1: But the place you find it, the place within
Speaker 1: yourself that you find out the answers to
Speaker 1: these kinds of questions, is in your soul.
Speaker 1: So, for example, when you can hear some
Speaker 1: people speak about their spiritual
Speaker 1: experiences, some people will speak, maybe
Speaker 1: in a very articulate and intellectually
Speaker 1: coherent way, about higher states and
Speaker 1: higher state experiences that they may have
Speaker 1: had, but have they been touched at the
Speaker 1: level of the soul by those experiences or
Speaker 1: has it merely been an interesting process
Speaker 1: that they went through that still leaves
Speaker 1: them fundamentally unchanged?
Speaker 1: When we're touched at the level of our soul,
Speaker 1: it's impossible for us to remain unchanged.
Speaker 1: It's impossible for us to remain unchanged.
Speaker 1: And the longer that I live and the longer
Speaker 1: that I teach and the more experience I have,
Speaker 1: I think that the development of the soul,
Speaker 1: the conscious development of the soul, the
Speaker 1: conscious cultivation of the soul, might be
Speaker 1: the most important part of spiritual
Speaker 1: practice and being involved in the
Speaker 1: spiritual process.
Speaker 1: Because, as to repeat what I said a few
Speaker 1: minutes ago, because the soul is the place
Speaker 1: where we find our capacity, or lack of
Speaker 1: capacity, for authenticity, deep
Speaker 1: trustworthiness, gravitas and
Speaker 1: single-pointedness in relationship to
Speaker 1: consciousness development and soul
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: Now, in Western postmodern culture, the
Speaker 1: soul is not something we speak about that
Speaker 1: often, and often when I hear people speak
Speaker 1: about the soul in spiritual context
Speaker 1: generally, to make a gross generalization
Speaker 1: it often seems to have more to do with the
Speaker 1: ego's deeper feelings than anything else.
Speaker 1: The soul is that part of ourself in which
Speaker 1: we glimpse what a deadly serious matter.
Speaker 1: The gift of life is the gift of conscious
Speaker 1: life, the gift of life that is consciously
Speaker 1: experienced in the context of
Speaker 1: self-effective awareness.
Speaker 1: The soul is the place where we realize this
Speaker 1: is not a game.
Speaker 1: We're not going to get any second chances,
Speaker 1: necessarily, and everything counts.
Speaker 1: The karma is real, there's no way out,
Speaker 1: there's no escape.
Speaker 1: There's no way out, there's no escape.
Speaker 1: And it's where we awaken to this chakra
Speaker 1: recognition that this is it, when, always,
Speaker 1: now, in the present moment, that this is
Speaker 1: really it, that this really counts, that
Speaker 1: all the important choices we make really
Speaker 1: count, and there's no extricating ourselves
Speaker 1: from a from karmic momentum.
Speaker 1: We're all part and parcel of a very complex
Speaker 1: process of karmic momentum.
Speaker 1: We can't disentangle ourselves from it, but
Speaker 1: we can, through spiritual practice,
Speaker 1: cultivate the capacity to consciously add
Speaker 1: that which is most positive to the
Speaker 1: complexity of the karmic process that we
Speaker 1: are entangled in.
Speaker 1: We can, through our own focused intention,
Speaker 1: bring some genuine positivity to the
Speaker 1: process and, through our own focused
Speaker 1: intention, bring some genuine positivity to
Speaker 1: the process.
Speaker 1: That's real, that will affect the process
Speaker 1: as a whole in its own way, because a lot of
Speaker 1: us like to think of ourselves as somehow
Speaker 1: not responsible and somehow that we're
Speaker 1: standing outside this vast cosmic process
Speaker 1: watching as kind of observers observers and
Speaker 1: victims, not co-creators.
Speaker 1: But when we wake up, in the way that I've
Speaker 1: been describing, we realize that we're
Speaker 1: always co-creators, whether we're conscious
Speaker 1: of it or not.
Speaker 1: We're always co-creators, whether we're
Speaker 1: conscious of it or not.
Speaker 1: And when you really begin to wake up, you
Speaker 1: realize number one, that that's true,
Speaker 1: there's no time off or days off or time out.
Speaker 1: Everything counts, and that the state of
Speaker 1: consciousness and the state of development
Speaker 1: of our souls is all important because that
Speaker 1: will indicate the ways in which we're going
Speaker 1: to be able to contribute positively or not
Speaker 1: to this cosmic unfolding that we're part
Speaker 1: and parcel of always.
Speaker 1: So in this context, we can think about the
Speaker 1: process in terms of spiritual practice and
Speaker 1: purification, the cultivation of
Speaker 1: purification and integration of higher
Speaker 1: wholeness and of a higher motivation
Speaker 1: Ultimately not for our own sake, not for
Speaker 1: our own liberation, ultimately not for our
Speaker 1: own sake, not for our own liberation, not
Speaker 1: for our own soul salvation and so that
Speaker 1: we'll be able to contribute that which is
Speaker 1: unimaginably wholesome and purely positive
Speaker 1: to this unconscious hurricane that is the
Speaker 1: complexity of this cosmic process that
Speaker 1: we're in the midst of.
Speaker 1: There's so much positivity that we can
Speaker 1: bring to this If we're willing to make the
Speaker 1: effort to do so and to sacrifice ourselves,
Speaker 1: to sacrifice our egos, because the ego
Speaker 1: always has another agenda.
Speaker 1: I want to do this and I want to do that
Speaker 1: because it's all for me, because the ego
Speaker 1: always has another agenda.
Speaker 1: I want to do this and I want to do that
Speaker 1: Because it's all for me.
Speaker 1: I want to do this and I want to do that.
Speaker 1: The ego almost always has another agenda in
Speaker 1: mind, and when we begin to see ourselves
Speaker 1: and when we can see ourselves and locate
Speaker 1: ourselves in the midst of this chaos and
Speaker 1: confusion, we begin to recognize how
Speaker 1: important our contribution of as much
Speaker 1: positivity as possible is, not as a
Speaker 1: secondary contribution, but as a
Speaker 1: fundamental contribution, as our essential
Speaker 1: gift to the universe, if we have enough
Speaker 1: courage to do it.
Speaker 1: So is your soul fundamentally identified
Speaker 1: with your ego and its fears and desires and
Speaker 1: grievances and frustrations and unresolved
Speaker 1: trauma?
Speaker 1: Is that what your soul is identified with?
Speaker 1: Is your soul identified with your bloodline,
Speaker 1: your biological identity and the profound
Speaker 1: sense of self-importance, in the positive
Speaker 1: sense, that that brings with it?
Speaker 1: Just think for a minute.
Speaker 1: Where is your soul identified If you're
Speaker 1: interested in enlightenment in a serious
Speaker 1: way, then that would mean that your soul is
Speaker 1: identified with eternity, that which is
Speaker 1: birthless and deathless, timeless and
Speaker 1: formless, and beginningless and endless,
Speaker 1: and that's timeless and formless and
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless.
Speaker 1: Or is your soul identified with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse?
Speaker 1: God forces, the force of creativity as the
Speaker 1: universe in the universe and in this
Speaker 1: process?
Speaker 1: It's very important and very helpful to
Speaker 1: learn how to do to the practice of
Speaker 1: contemplative inquiry, contemplative
Speaker 1: self-scrutiny.
Speaker 1: Contemplative inquiry for you and I do this
Speaker 1: myself as often as possible, like every day
Speaker 1: is to learn how to practice to discriminate
Speaker 1: between the concerns of your ego and the
Speaker 1: concerns of your soul, because the ego can
Speaker 1: have very strong feelings, very strong
Speaker 1: likes and dislikes and all kinds of
Speaker 1: preferences, and they can be distracting,
Speaker 1: we all know.
Speaker 1: But your soul feels things even more deeply
Speaker 1: than your ego does, as powerful as your
Speaker 1: egoic feelings can be.
Speaker 1: And are you aware, as you're going through
Speaker 1: the ups and downs, of how the ego might
Speaker 1: feel and how the soul might feel?
Speaker 1: So are you aware of the difference between
Speaker 1: the two, because the soul is always very
Speaker 1: concerned with what you know and what you
Speaker 1: feel is most important.
Speaker 1: It's very important to understand that what
Speaker 1: I'm calling the true self, the grounded
Speaker 1: being, doesn't have preferences.
Speaker 1: It's free from all events or anything and
Speaker 1: everything that ever happens.
Speaker 1: The true self is free from and not
Speaker 1: identified with, any of it.
Speaker 1: That's why it's the awakened soul that has
Speaker 1: to be our guide, because the true self is
Speaker 1: pure, unqualified, absolute is-ness.
Speaker 1: It doesn't make preferences, it doesn't
Speaker 1: make choices because it's always already
Speaker 1: free.
Speaker 1: So a big part of spiritual practice is
Speaker 1: learning how to distinguish between the
Speaker 1: soul's feelings and preferences and the
Speaker 1: ego's feelings and preferences.
Speaker 1: People who are living life from their soul
Speaker 1: are much deeper people, much deeper beings.
Speaker 1: They have more weight, ascension beings
Speaker 1: because they're much more connected to
Speaker 1: depth and value and meaning and purpose and
Speaker 1: the significance of history and karma and
Speaker 1: direction.
Speaker 1: So we don't want to swim around on the
Speaker 1: surface of life.
Speaker 1: surface of life Lost in the egos, fears and
Speaker 1: desires, likes and dislikes, as so many
Speaker 1: people do these days, lost, so deeply lost
Speaker 1: and not even knowing that they're lost.
Speaker 1: Is it worse to be lost or is it worse to be
Speaker 1: lost and not know it?
Speaker 1: I think it's worse to be lost and not know
Speaker 1: it.
Speaker 1: If you're lost and you know you're lost,
Speaker 1: you're not completely lost.
Speaker 1: But if you're lost and you don't know
Speaker 1: you're lost, then you're really lost.
Speaker 1: And if you think you're lost and it scares
Speaker 1: you, that's good.
Speaker 1: Sometimes it's good to be scared of being
Speaker 1: lost because it will help you to care about
Speaker 1: deeper matters.
Speaker 1: So, as you meditate, as you practice in
Speaker 1: self-inquiry, as you practice, as you
Speaker 1: practice in self-inquiry, as you practice
Speaker 1: contemplation, as you scoot in your own
Speaker 1: internal thoughts and feelings, highs and
Speaker 1: lows, ups and downs, try to find out where
Speaker 1: you're at in relationship to your soul.
Speaker 1: What is your soul that you care about?
Speaker 1: What is your soul focused on?
Speaker 1: Where are you at in relationship to your
Speaker 1: soul?
Speaker 1: Because it's my belief.
Speaker 1: I can't prove this, but it's my belief that
Speaker 1: the soul, as I said, is the metaphysical
Speaker 1: organ in which there's continuity from life
Speaker 1: to life.
Speaker 1: I always ask people is there continuity in
Speaker 1: the material process of the evolving cosmos
Speaker 1: cosmos is sorry is there continuity in the
Speaker 1: in the evolution of the energy and matter
Speaker 1: that make up the evolving universe?
Speaker 1: Is there continuity from the, from the big
Speaker 1: bang until now?
Speaker 1: Is there continuity?
Speaker 1: Is, is there continuity in the past 14
Speaker 1: billion years of evolutionary becoming at
Speaker 1: the level of matter and energy?
Speaker 1: And people would say yes, there's
Speaker 1: continuity.
Speaker 1: So if there's continuity at the level of
Speaker 1: energy and matter for the last 14 billion
Speaker 1: years, at the level of matter and energy,
Speaker 1: which is considered to be the outside of
Speaker 1: the universe, why would there not also be
Speaker 1: continuity which is considered to be the
Speaker 1: outside of the universe?
Speaker 1: Why would there not also be continuity on
Speaker 1: the inside, at the level of interiority?
Speaker 1: Because, as integral philosophy has made us
Speaker 1: aware, universe has an inside and an
Speaker 1: outside.
Speaker 1: Matter and energy of the exterior,
Speaker 1: subjectivity, interiority, are the inside.
Speaker 1: So if the exterior of the universe has
Speaker 1: continuity, it makes sense that the
Speaker 1: interior of the universe, which is
Speaker 1: interiority itself, is part of that
Speaker 1: continuity, that there is continuity in the
Speaker 1: interior of the evolving universe, in the
Speaker 1: inside of the evolving universe, and what
Speaker 1: I've been referring to as the soul, I
Speaker 1: believe, is part and parcel of the
Speaker 1: continuity of that interiority, I believe,
Speaker 1: part and parcel of the continuity of that
Speaker 1: materiality.
Speaker 1: So what I'm calling the soul has been
Speaker 1: present in some partial form from the very
Speaker 1: beginning.
Speaker 1: It's been part of this process for a very
Speaker 1: long time.
Speaker 1: So the soul is the part of us that relates
Speaker 1: to the biggest vision of becoming your
Speaker 1: biggest and my biggest glimpse or vision or
Speaker 1: insight into the nature of being part of a
Speaker 1: cosmic process.
Speaker 1: It's been a process for a very long time.
Speaker 1: That's beginning to awaken to itself
Speaker 1: through you, through me, but it's glimpsing
Speaker 1: the significance of being part of this for
Speaker 1: so long, of being inherently meshed in this
Speaker 1: process for so long.
Speaker 1: And when you awaken to that and you
Speaker 1: recognize it, it's awe-inspiring and
Speaker 1: overwhelming Because it means we've all
Speaker 1: been here for a very long time.
Speaker 1: We just haven't known it.
Speaker 1: So as we wake up to how long we've been
Speaker 1: here, then the self tries to grapple with
Speaker 1: how can I possibly take responsibility for
Speaker 1: all of this?
Speaker 1: Who am I if I've been around for all this
Speaker 1: time?
Speaker 1: Little old me.
Speaker 1: It's enormous, very challenging, daunting,
Speaker 1: very challenging, daunting.
Speaker 1: So how conscious are we to how big all this
Speaker 1: is and how profound it all really is?
Speaker 1: The more we can face and come to terms with
Speaker 1: the enormity of this process that we are
Speaker 1: inherently a part and parcel of, the more
Speaker 1: profound will be the life that we live and
Speaker 1: our reasons for living it.
Speaker 1: Thank you, so your soul, or the soul, can
Speaker 1: see beyond the limitations of this small
Speaker 1: life you're living right.
Speaker 1: I'm not saying your life is small, but the
Speaker 1: limited nature of how we think about what
Speaker 1: it means to be alive.
Speaker 1: The reason why it's so important to
Speaker 1: meditate every day is so that when we have
Speaker 1: these glimpses which are often hard when we
Speaker 1: get these glimpses way beyond the narrow
Speaker 1: confines of our ego and its narrow
Speaker 1: relationship to personal history, when we
Speaker 1: get these glimpses it widens our
Speaker 1: perspective so much and awakens us to the
Speaker 1: shocking reality of a part of this.
Speaker 1: You can see the vast process that
Speaker 1: desperately needs us to be conscious of it.
Speaker 1: Sometimes, when I think in a in a mythic
Speaker 1: context, in a mythic, anthropocentric way,
Speaker 1: about the nature of the absolute principle
Speaker 1: or the God principle, just for fun,
Speaker 1: sometimes I choose to think about the
Speaker 1: nature of the God principle as an
Speaker 1: anthropomorphic form, just as a
Speaker 1: metaphysical exercise.
Speaker 1: So in that context, sometimes I imagine how,
Speaker 1: if I was her, I'm being politically correct.
Speaker 1: Sometimes I imagine, if I was her, how
Speaker 1: desperate I would be for my children to of
Speaker 1: being politically correct.
Speaker 1: Sometimes I imagine, if I was her, how
Speaker 1: desperate I would be for my children to
Speaker 1: wake up and to see me, because I knew, as
Speaker 1: long as they could see me there would be
Speaker 1: hope for the future.
Speaker 1: And as long as they couldn't really see me
Speaker 1: clearly and feel me and know who I was.
Speaker 1: They would remain lost in delusion.
Speaker 1: So that's an anthropocentric contemplation.
Speaker 1: But we don't have to think about it that
Speaker 1: way.
Speaker 1: We can say the reality of consciousness is
Speaker 1: desperate for its own self-recognition.
Speaker 1: The same thing, very good.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to stop myself now, but I'm
Speaker 1: kind of rambling.
Speaker 1: So I made the fundamental point I was
Speaker 1: trying to make.
Speaker 1: And the fundamental point was that your
Speaker 1: soul and what we're calling the soul, your
Speaker 1: soul, my soul, the soul, its capacity for
Speaker 1: it, identifies with where you're at in
Speaker 1: terms of the stage of development you're at,
Speaker 1: from egocentric, death-centric, to
Speaker 1: world-centric, to cosmos-centric.
Speaker 1: So what your soul will be capable of in
Speaker 1: terms of identifying with what's most
Speaker 1: important will depend upon which stage of
Speaker 1: development you're at as an evolving
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: And remember that the soul is the deepest
Speaker 1: part of the self.
Speaker 1: It's still personal.
Speaker 1: The ego is purely personal.
Speaker 1: The frontal self or ego is purely personal.
Speaker 1: So the soul is a much deeper part of who
Speaker 1: you are and who I am, but it's still
Speaker 1: personal because it's still about that
Speaker 1: which experiences birth and death.
Speaker 1: It's going through a process of change.
Speaker 1: The true self, your true self and my true
Speaker 1: self is the deepest dimension of who you
Speaker 1: are, the deepest dimension of your reality
Speaker 1: self, and it's never born and never dies,
Speaker 1: and it's therefore eternal and therefore
Speaker 1: has no preferences.
Speaker 1: So the true self doesn't care, your true
Speaker 1: self doesn't care.
Speaker 1: That's why it's free.
Speaker 1: That's why we could say that it might be
Speaker 1: more important to have an awakened soul
Speaker 1: than awakening to the true self in which
Speaker 1: the soul itself has been awakened.
Speaker 1: Yet I think the most important thing is
Speaker 1: care, is awakening to deeper and higher
Speaker 1: capacities for care.
Speaker 1: I think awakening to deeper and higher
Speaker 1: capacities for care is more important than
Speaker 1: the experience of inner freedom.
Speaker 1: Care and awakening to deeper and higher
Speaker 1: capacity for care can be an enormous burden,
Speaker 1: because if you care, if you really care, if
Speaker 1: you allow yourself to care that much and to
Speaker 1: experience that much care, it means you're
Speaker 1: going to have to do something about it,
Speaker 1: whereas if you are merely free, you don't
Speaker 1: have to care.
Speaker 1: So sometimes, paradoxically, the pursuit of
Speaker 1: freedom for its own sake can be, can
Speaker 1: inhibit certain kinds of spiritual
Speaker 1: development, believe it or not.
Speaker 1: Very good.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to stop talking now and then
Speaker 1: in a couple of minutes I can try and answer
Speaker 1: some questions if you'd like.
Speaker 1: Let's hope we all will aspire to become
Speaker 1: soulful people, soulful of soul, bursting
Speaker 1: with soul.
Speaker 1: Soul is care, and care is soul.
Speaker 1: Thank, you, you.